[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show and
the boys are back in town with the first
three episodes of the third season it's
just dropped on amazon prime video and
throughout this we're going to be
breaking down the easter eggs recapping
the plot and also discussing where
things could be going in the future i
want to get straight into it but we will
be going through the show week by week
for every episode so if you want to stay
up to date with the breakdowns then make
sure you subscribe without the way thank
you for clicking this now let's get into
the boys season 3. now last season we
saw the batman v superman parody dawn of
the seven being filmed and this entry
opens with a scene from that in which we
see how vort have marketed the fall of
stormfront the truth about her was
exposed last time and this entry very
much frames her takedown completely
different to how it really happened
propaganda has been used throughout
history especially in film and there's a
great documentary discussing the movies
made about stalin after the second world
war these painted out the true events
completely differently to how they
happened in order to prop up the leader
similar to the supes now we open with a
lot of potential for shadowing as we
have not only vote tower and flames but
also the statue of soulja boy which has
been knocked over last season we saw
this at the stormfront and homeland a
rally and it was meant to showcase to us
the apparent fallen soldier that was
supposed to be the best of us from the
world's greatest generation however as
we learn this is all in fact a lie and
the truth about soulja boy isn't all
it's cracked up to be we also see an
advert for a trains turbo rush and a bus
and this is the soft drink that we know
from the commercials will be a kylie
jenner pepsi parody at this point we get
a major cameo and discover that
charlie's their own is back for her
second superhero dropping after the end
of but we'll we'll not get into other
spoilers there now ironically she has
blonde hair and blue eyes
characteristics of the aryan race that
hitler wanted to push similar to him
stormfront didn't have these
characteristics either but homelander
did which is why she ends up fascinated
with him she ends up dropping a similar
speech to the ending of the season 2
finale and we discover that she's still
alive and being kept in care of wart
even though they're publicly disavowing
her she says homeland is on his own to
which stonefront says he's not alone
potentially riffing on the line from
infinity war said by black widow
he'll die alone as will you
she's not alone
sad i knew that without looking it up
and this is followed by a train saying
what can't let you guys have all the fun
homelander also calls her a nazi
which is actually what starlight did at
the end of season two they didn't do
that a bit of hate in superhero movies
at this point you know which it's
basically where the villains and good
guys fire a beam at each other and it
meets in the middle they do it all the
time stop doing it now the opening of
this is very much focused on homelander
who's clearly had a shift in his persona
after realizing that the team is all
secretly gunning for him maeve of course
has the evidence that he was complicit
in the plane crash and throughout the
three episodes we see as he becomes more
and more unhinged this is really set off
by the apparent death of stormfront
though there is potential that she will
come back the red carpet is absolutely
packed and it's at this point we're
introduced to supersonic aka starlight's
ex-boyfriend we learned that he was
previously called drummer boy and in the
comics this was the name of the person
that she dated when she was part of the
young americans he actually seems like a
nice guy in the show whereas in the
comics he cheated on her with another
member called holy mary you also get a
release the snyder cut reference upon
discovering that adam burke the director
had to shelve the movie because of the
stormfront reveal but the internet
rallied together behind this hashtag to
get them to put it out last time a train
was cut from the team however the
reshoots dropped him back in as a member
for the final battle on the red carpet
huey bumps into homelander aka mr stelio
girl come episode 3 which is a nice arc
this is reflected in aetrain who bumps
into the opposite side of him on the
carpet and you have the parallels of the
man who took away his last girlfriend
and the one trying to take away his
current one a train is also asked about
another race like the one he had in
season one it is possible that this will
be up against supersonic who is also a
speedster it's also here that huey
starts to get hints that something is
off with victoria aka nadia who we learn
a lot more about her character is based
on viktor newman from the comics who was
a ward plant within the government
unlike victoria he didn't have powers
and the guy was a complete [ __ ] who
they used to gain power he was the vice
president before the president was
killed and he then took over his spot
potentially teasing at where victoria's
all could go i love the way that edgar
keeps his eye on homeland as he's
delivering his highly rehearsed speech
and it reminded me a lot of the one that
lady gaga did whilst promoting a star is
born there can be a hundred people in
the room and 99 don't believe in you
but
i had this one
incredible talent
with me and there can be a hundred
people in the room and 99 don't believe
in you and you just need one to believe
in you and that was him so you can have
100 people in the room that are watching
you and 99 don't believe in you and one
does and that was him so you know there
could be a hundred people in the room
and 99 don't believe but all it takes is
one you know 100 people anyway you get
the point with that now cut to ashley
banging burke in the bathroom and she
insults him by saying tony gilroy had to
reshoot all his stuff because he's a
fraud gilroy is an american filmmaker
that's worked on a ton of movies and we
also get more of ashley's hair coming
out seems like she's suffering from
trichotillomania which is a mental
disorder in which someone cannot resist
the urge to pull their own hair out her
character is also based on jess bradley
from the comics who's all culminated
with her literally pulling her hair out
as she was set up to take the fall by
fort belly bumps in a huey in the
bathroom and because he's now a suit he
takes a dislike to the [ __ ] but after
the end of this episode hughes starts to
realize how his ways won't work curtis
billy frenchy and chemical carrying out
surveillance on a soup's party this
happened a lot earlier in the comics and
was also something that popped up in the
boys diabolical episode pusherman in
both that and the source material we'd
see a lot of sordid sex things play out
like the ant-man parody that we get here
he's named termite and we learned from
the boy's youtube channel and he made a
movie called rocket romance about a doll
that we also see here can't really show
any of this stuff and certainly not what
happens in the next scene which
yeah i tell you now when the trailer
dropped i thought this would be a nod to
the meme about ant-man going up thanos's
butt but it's worse it's so much worse
now we do get a nod to that at one point
and also see kimiko fantasizing about
singing dream a little dream of me the
trailer had her in frenchie dancing at
one point in what looked like a musical
so i'm guessing she's gonna imagine
she's got a voice throughout the season
hughie wakes up with starlight and we
hear the song uptown girl by billy joel
this is not only about starlight but
also nadia who hewey learns about at the
end of the entry it's played in the
credits and as we learned last season
hughie is a massive billy joel fan simon
peg returns as his father and in case
you don't know the comic version of huey
was actually based on him peg was due to
play the character but by the time
production really got rolling he'd aged
out of the role which is why we got jack
quaid instead huey now works at the
federal bureau of superhuman affairs an
fbi parody established secretly by vote
we discovered that victoria has brought
in more soups than anyone else but this
was likely just bought handing in ones
that they couldn't reign in we also see
a robert singer for president anne and
he's appeared throughout the seasons
working closely with board who we
discovered donated to his campaign again
they're trying to get a footing in the
white house which i think will be the
route that the victoria character goes
clearly based on aoc they're definitely
taking jabs at both sides and it's only
when huey realizes that the whole system
is rigged that he finally starts to get
anywhere out of an unknown location
billy goes to meet with ryan who we saw
last time was left in the care of
mallory and the cia they're clearly
terrified homelander is going to go
after him and have artillery throughout
the area even though we know it won't
really work against him i can see the
season having homelander finally going
off the deep end and attempting to get
him back at some point he arrives with
the kinect 4 he was shopping for on
amazon which nice bit of corporate
synergy there we actually get a lot of
mallory's backstory in episode 3 and in
the comics mallory was a man that
oversaw all of the boy's operation named
greg mallory he ended up turning on the
supes after they wiped out his platoon
at the battle of the bulge which is
changed up to nicaragua on the cameron
coulson show homelander bumps into the
deep who we discover is now more popular
than he is cameron coulson is the host
of the youtube news shows that amazon
have been dropping on the series and
they've definitely fleshed out a lot of
the characters now the church of the
collective were a pretty obvious
metaphor for scientology and he even
gets called leia remini who has spoke
out about what happened when she stepped
out you also discover that shia
labeouf's ghostwriter wrote a deep's
book titled deeper he apologizes to
homelander for being more popular than
him states he's not and homelander ends
up putting him forward come the end of
episode 3. homelander is there to talk
about stormfront and i love how he's
like so let me say it again cam before
he just goes into the script i may be a
superhero but i'm also just a man who
fell in love with the wrong woman who's
the man who fell for the wrong woman uh
for the wrong woman but out of crisis
comes changed
and mother's milk ends up buying her a
flavor flav necklace the guy of course
wears hip-hop t-shirts throughout the
seasons and we'll talk about this more
in the later episodes he clearly wants
to repair the relationship with his ex
but she's got a new man now who dresses
up as homelander which is a symbol that
he's been fighting against could do one
of the major plot points in the season
compound v24 which will allow someone to
get the powers of a supes for 24 hours
this massively reflects the comic book
storyline and in those the boys ended up
taking compound v in order to level the
playing field robert singer gets a
nickname dakota bob and in the comics
this was the name of the president vic
ends up killing him through the use of a
rabid wolverine which allows him to slot
in the place of leadership after saying
that he'll reject the use of compound v
edgar mentions some of the strings he
can pull in congress which is when we
cut to victoria he's clearly playing his
hand and though the series isn't
following the comics exactly can kinda
see newman being pushed for the white
house edgar also talks about how the
hero bit of superhero ruined his
original plan because he's created
egotistical idiots that want to be
worshiped he gives it five years and due
to his closeness to mallory he might
even end up being the person that is
tipped off the cia he was also clearly
getting newman to reign in more sordid
supes with the bureau so can kind of see
that being revealed later down the line
now singer also references black noir
destroying a cafe in lagos which was the
same location that scarlet witch
accidentally killed lots of people out
in civil war in newman's office we get
lip service to cold snap stacker and
airbus we're all members of the g-men
and g-whiz i love how vic says she built
this place without being covered in
blood and guts which isn't really true
is it victoria cut to the flat iron
building aka the boys hideout which is
the same location that it was in the
comics it was also used for the daily
bugle and remy's spider-man and as i've
been saying it's all connected
termite is no longer gonna be prosecuted
and it is possible that he'll pop up
again curtis billy's home and we see a
little bulldog cookie jar a reference to
his dog tara from the comics and show
edgar offers starlight the chance to
become co-captain of the seven and
though she rejects this at first tempted
with real power she ends up accepting
however this backfires when homelander
goes off the deep end and he announces
that they're in love later on it's all a
form of control and starlight ends up
being a judge on american hero an
american idol parody along with
supersonic we meet the other contestants
and his mention of capes for christ his
band super sweet and the songs are a bit
creepy especially especially that one
about the driver's license in episode
three now huey gets jealous over
starlight's past and this could
potentially lead him into taking more
compound v wasn't really in the comics
but they did have a span of issues where
he got jealous and they split up which
might be triggered by the revelation at
the end homelander starts getting
annoyed that a train is putting on
weight and we later see a magazine cover
up butcher's house which has several
headlines about getting abs billy throws
several darts at this which also have
bulldogs on them on top of a union jack
maeve witnesses homelanders ran
firsthand and decides to reach out to
billy and speaking of first hand
homelander gets some handy help from
stormfront hurai is now fully missing
and in the comics much like the show
this was stabbed out at one point
riding here is really sharp and it's
twisted seeing her say the homelander
that no one suffers like he suffers
while she's unable to move she's clearly
trying to lead him into creating a
master race but he views himself as that
which is something we discussed in a lot
of our season 2 breakdowns maeve arrives
with v24 and also a file on soulja boy
which labels his racketeering in episode
3 we learned that he and the cia ran
contraband to the united states and that
they even pushed it into minority
neighborhoods really really messed up
but the cover story stands in place that
he stopped a reactor meltdown payback
with a number one team but we learned
that the seven overtook them now we get
a scene with billion homelander that
could be a hallucination due to the
reveal later on that butcher has visions
of him talking on the tv however i do
believe that this is real and it feels
very in line with the comics namely the
scene in which the boys in seven end up
calling a truce things don't go that way
though and as billy glances over to
where he hid the compound be homelander
disappears at night we see mother's
milk's collection of newspaper
scrappings that explain why he hates the
soups if you look at the first report it
clears him of any wrongdoing in the
death of a queen's family on this report
we can see that three members of the
milk family were murdered by him it says
that he caused their car to crash but
alleges that they tried to run him down
there's also one for huey's girlfriend
who was killed by a train and a report
that lists soldier boy as a fallen hero
ford very much gave him a captain
america reputation pretending that he
died as a martyr the episode ends with
huey seeing victoria killing someone
from the home she was raised at and we
finally get more on her powers now i
don't think she can explode heads per se
more so she destroys organic matter by
looking at it this is why tony's hand
and jaw end up exploding rather than his
full head in the second season when
homelander arrived at the rally she kept
her gaze focused on him and i do believe
she could take him out if needs be tony
also mentions red river which pops up in
the comics at several points this is
meant to be a play on blackwater and in
the source material it was a location
that was basically an independent
military contractor tony wants to expose
it using victoria's platform but she
refuses and then kills him now episode 2
opens with vtv television for women
which shows the made-for-tv film that
recounts the deep's time in the church
of the collective the movie titled not
without my dolphin basically puts the
idea in place that the church is bad and
we get billy zane starring as alistair
ordonna zayn starred in titanic and that
had an ocean in it so deep
easter eggs all around now i think the
title is a reference to not without my
daughter a 1991 film about a mother and
daughter fleeing from iran anyway we
also get a mention of branding a
possible real-life note of the cult
nexium that had smallville star alison
mack as a member plagued with visions of
homelander and nightmares overtaking
compound v24 billy weighs up whether he
should become a monster in order to
fight them but come the end of the entry
he realizes that he has to it's also
homeland his birthday and though judy
dench will be in attendance stormfront
won't he goes to her bedside at the
start of the episode and she's not
really responsive we find out later on
in the episode that she apparently took
her own life but whether this is true or
not remains to be seen we do hear that
she bit down on her own tongue which
likely made her choke or potentially she
was killed by someone else now in the
comics black noir actually completely
dismantled homelander's image of himself
by sending him photographs where he
looked like he was carrying out very
heinous acts this slowly sent him insane
and it allowed noir to carry out his
endgame of killing him ashley has no
idea how stormfront managed to do this
and potentially we could learn it was
noir behind it all now billy goes to see
mother's milk and he brings his daughter
a toy construction set of vote tower on
it we catch homelander and starlight and
what appears to be them fighting
potentially foreshadowing the battle
that could end up coming down the line
you might also notice that the vort
studios logo up in the top corner is
very reminiscent of the marvel studios
one he tries to get milk into avenging
his family but he's angered by this
because his own father ignored his kids
whilst obsessing over everything to do
with their deaths it's something he
doesn't want for himself or jeanine and
though he initially says he won't get
involved he hands over some of his files
this includes one for gunpowder a
punisher s character that we meet later
on at an nra parody event he brings up
his signature gun a vr15 which is a play
on the controversial firearm in ar-15
his license plate also reads 2a forever
which stands for second amendment
forever aka the right to bear arms in
the source material he was a mix of
several comic book characters and his
helmet design was also based around
judge dredd along with his shoot first
asked questions later mentality however
here they go the extra mile and very
much make him award to soulja boy like
bucky was cut to vault land and we see
how maeve's sexuality has pretty much
been brought into the marketing routine
so that the company can seem inclusive
and score points with people they even
have brave maeve's veggie tacos which
veggie tacos dear me now in a blinking
you'll miss a moment we can also see
others including systemically oppressed
tacos intersectional ones and inclusive
quesadillas there's also blm blts woke
walk lgb turkey legs and it's clear
would have just commodified things
people feel strongly about so that they
can sell products that don't really have
anything to do with it inside the
carnival we find the crimson countess a
skull at which parody who's probably the
only person that's actually nicer than
the superhero she's based upon her
powers are pretty limited when compared
to the level that wanda is at now but
she can't shoot sparkly blasts out of
her hand that can turn you inside out
she ends up killing someone in a
homeland a mascot suit again potentially
foreshadowing the upcoming battles
between payback and the seven she kind
of shows the life that's ahead of the
soups that lose their popularity and
very much represents the aging pop star
once they step out of the limelight it's
also possible that her obsession with
chimpanzees isn't not jane goodall who's
seen as the world's foremost expert on
chimps you also get a film that shows
the origins of soulja boy and this is
riffing on the one from the captain
america museum in the winter soldier
kotel mlander who really starts his
mission to destroy starlight and as he
can't do it physically due to her
popularity he has to do it mentally he
wants her to sing him happy birthday in
the style of marilyn monroe like she did
at jfk it's been long thought the pair
had an affair and this song will help to
add to their romantic connection that he
lies about later on he also gets some
chorus girls to come in wearing her
previous uniform which he felt
uncomfortable in to demean her so she
doesn't look like a co-captain edgar
puts his foot down i think that rather
than killing the president like how he
does in the comics at home lander will
rip his head off instead which will be
how he shows he's no longer under votes
control a train tries to pitch his
rebranding idea to show how he's
connected to his roots and he wants a
docky movie called a trainer africa to
follow his journey it's clearly a pr
stunt though and everyone tells him how
he pretty much forgot everyone as soon
as he got famous still he shows up in
the new suit later on and we know from
the trailers that he'll be doing a kylie
jenner pepsi ad parody huey starts to
investigate red river and we see the
kids there including a teleporter and a
spider-man parody that can climb on
walls i love how the teacher is hopping
on crutches showing that one of the kids
clearly messed her up like i will do if
you don't hit that thumbs up button
now later on she says it's always good
having a superhuman parent because
there's far less chance of a fatality
and the episode in the boys diabolical
at dealt with red river had the kids
abandoned there returning to their folks
to brutally murder them after realizing
victoria or nadia was recruited by edgar
he decides to reach out properly to
belly who we catch having a literal
contest with gunpowder
we catch his sharpshooter abilities as
he ricochets a bullet into belly's cheek
which is not a dead shot from dc comics
billy ends up using compound v24 to kill
him finally embracing the dark side of
it now across town we get another not to
dc when we catch homeland carrying out
his annual birthday save this is a super
messed up scene and i feel like it's
pulling from the section all-star
superman in which super steps in to stop
a girl called reagan from jumping off a
building in this scene homelander lends
about stormfront and though we don't
learn if he pushed her or not either
talked her into it or did it himself we
discover the girl jumping as a jewish
woman called chelsea and homelander
doing this could also potentially hint
at there being racial implications
because of stormfront's death lots of
potential things to read into it along
with homelander comparing himself to
jesus due to him viewing his life as
being that of servitude he also says
that he doesn't even know when his real
birthday is because it was made up by a
marketing department in the same way
that the 25th of december was assigned
to jesus even though it wasn't that date
cameraman fell in the scene and there's
a reference to roger dickens a
cinematographer that has an amazing body
of work the entry finishes up with
butcher learning about the cia's
involvement with payback and mallory's
connection to this this takes us into
the third episode which explores a lot
of the backstory of the group at
homelander's birthday after a heckler
shouts out about stormfront he has a
meltdown similar to the one in network
much like this it makes people rally
behind him instead of against him
finally he's completely unsanitized and
we even see janine's stepdad rising into
this showing how he's altered his fan
base he finally flips around his
catchphrase and says we're not the real
heroes he is and that we all need saving
great way to close things out no no no
turn it off
baby got your license to try
got your license
so episode 3 starts off at the little
miss hero pageant where we see annie
january being forced by her pushy mother
to perform hit me baby one more time
this was of course the breakout hit for
britney spears that's often accused of
pushing the schoolgirl image which it is
a bit weird in it mate now britney much
like annie was a child star and due to
years of being in the limelight she
developed mental health issues and
recently has only been able to escape
her conservatorship this involves either
a person or organization having complete
control over someone's finances and life
choices which is very much reflected in
how vault rules over starlight other
performance goes well she ends up
clenching her fists behind her back
signifying how she's performing for the
audience but is really bottled up with
anger this is a motif that pops about
the end of the entry when homelander
announces that they're in a relationship
ashley runs to tell homeland of the good
news and we see an american flag hanging
up behind him against the wall like
patton's speech to the third army
everything's coming up homelander and
alongside starlight there's never been
heroes that are more popular back at the
boys hq we see mother's milk wearing an
nwa t-shirt and also hear their song
express yourself playing in the
background huey goes back to the boys
and hanging up we can see some of their
wanted pictures referencing the ones
from the comics huey wears a t-shirt for
the last waltz a film on the concert of
a band called the band directed by
martin scorsese kimiko breaks his arm
and this is reffing on a scene from the
comics in which she did it in a hospital
after getting attacked by stormfront
huey ended up taking him in from her
that she wanted and there she broke his
arm on tv we see american hero playing
out and an interview with silva kincaid
this is a big character from the comics
and originally it was thought cindy
would be her she had a similar skill set
and used to cover up crimes for wart and
eventually this sent her over the edge
and she used her powers on herself to
end her own life her powers seem to be
exactly the same judging by the
description and once she's rejected from
the seven this could end up happening
too now friendship meet sherry who says
she's went back to work for nina who we
learn is a big drug dealer she's based
on little nina from the comics who made
a version of compound v that she used to
create supes however this backfired a
lot and their heads exploded a little
nina was like wonder cause she loved her
vibrator her butcher put an explosive in
this and it destroyed her and the plane
that she was traveling on butcher in the
show wants to reach out to her and he
might even end up giving her compound
v24 nina could end up copying this and
potentially she might sell it on the
black market now the boys confront
mallory and we learn the truth about the
cia's operation similar to what we get
here in the comics the soups were
completely useless and it really
dissuaded the army from using vort's
help everyone is slowly starting to
realize the thing they want isn't all
it's cracked up to be and we see this in
starlight who warn supersonic about the
seven and also through a train we
discover that every time he runs he's
playing russian roulette with his heart
and that he could blow out at any moment
lastly it's of course cena mallory who
we learn work with the soups during the
iran contra deal a lot of this well not
the supersport but a lot of it is true
allegedly and they also sold arms into
the country which caused a major scandal
at the time here we meet three
characters who wound in the comics
namely mindstorm and also the tnt twins
the latter of these is based on the
wunder twins from dc and similar to them
their powers set off when they touch
hands swado also flies like how he does
in the comics and we finally learn all
the ins and outs about black noir now
full spoilers for the comics so if you
don't want to know what happens in them
then skip ahead to the next section it's
a bit fast if i just dive into it so
giving you a bit time here three
two
so in the comics black noir was revealed
to be a clone of homelander that had
been created by vo to take him down if
he ever went rogue however having this
mission programmed into him and never
being able to carry it out made him
insane because he looked like homelander
he started carrying out heinous acts
dressed as him which he then
photographed he sent these to homelander
and he believed that he'd blacked out
and done them when he wasn't able to
control himself this slowly sent him
insane and after he murdered the
president black noir was finally able to
carry out his mission and kill him now
we know from the boy's diabolical that
black noir has also been brought in to
take out homelander if he goes too far
however episode 3 further confirms that
he's not a clone we did of course have
the unmasking moment in the second
season and he's always been played by
black actors actually did a theory video
talking about why i thought he might be
a clone of stan edgar and though we
don't learn much about him it seems like
the pair have some relationship now
black noir doesn't want to wear his mask
but due to racial issues he's told he
should put it on this could perhaps be a
comment on the black panther posters and
how they were sent to market in china
the american one showed chadwick boseman
with his face fully on display but in
china this was covered by a mask really
crappy business practices and i wonder
if they're gonna explore it more
throughout the series black noir says he
wants to be the eddie murphy of the
group but being badly burnt meant he had
to hide behind a mask possibly building
his hate for homelander the racism is
also murder in homelander 2 who says he
refuses to let a muslim into the seven
which is why he pushes for the deep to
rejoin the ranks starlight is furious
and she attempts to blackmail homelander
with the flight video he calls her bluff
and basically outlines his plan to
destroy the planet if his image comes
crashing down it's a terrifying moment
that really shows the change that's now
in homeland i will skip the deep sex
scene yeah but homelander does mentally
torture him later on by forcing him to
eat a live octopus named timothy that he
had his eyes on guy begs for his life
and has kids but homelander and
cassandra tell him to do it showing the
coercive control that they both have
over him this control is also reflected
in other characters throughout the
entire episode and he ends up reaching
out to huey who tells her to stick it
out even though she wants to leave this
is very reminiscent of her mother at the
start of the episode who wouldn't let
her quit the charade back with a train
we get a mention of blue hawk a new
character for the series likely based on
groundhog who appeared in both the
comics and the boys diabolical now in
nicaragua we hear from the crimson
countess that the russians apparently
used a weapon to kill soulja boy and
they ended up taking his body similar to
the winter soldier however we know that
he's hidden out somewhere and that he
now has the ability to fight concussive
blasts from his chest similar to havoc
from the x-men wrestling with the
compound v24 inside of him but she ends
up taking out his anger over learning
the truth on both malory and ryan who
almost sparks up his eyelashes similar
to homelander he showcases he could end
up becoming just like his father and
mallory even talks about how anger
within billy is exactly the same as the
one that his father had in the end
supersonic ends up joining the seven
along with the deep homelander lies and
says that it was starlight's idea to
bring him back and at this point he
announces that their hashtag homelight
that closes out the episode and what a
trilogy it was so glad to be back with
the boys it's super [ __ ] up challenges
you sometimes and it's got a dark sense
of humor that i really enjoy just go a
bit over the top sometimes but on the
whole i had a lot of fun with this one
now i feel like the show just holds a
mirror up to society and comic book
culture in general this is pretty much
taking over the entire world and the way
they parody our current icons is
absolutely brilliant so happy they're
back and i'd love to hear your thoughts
on the three new episodes we're running
a competition right now and giving away
three copies of the batman on the 15th
of june and all you have to do to be on
the chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episodes
if you pick the comments at random at
the end of the month and the winners of
the last one are on screen right now so
if that's you then message me on twitter
heavyspoilers you want something else to
watch then make sure you check out our
brighton of obi-wan which will be linked
on screen right now you go over all the
all the stuff in the new episode so go
ahead over there
and if not i'll bloody kick off [ __ ]
bloody kick off thanks for sticking
through this video take care peace